hi everybody I am lauren zima coming to
you from ETS makeshift England right
here so our lives are stressful guys
times are crazy
luckily the British Royals have blessed
us all with some sorely needed joy in
2018 they are giving us a royal wedding
we're a fantastic team we know real yes
the et family is so excited for that
fantastic team of Prince Harry and Megan
Markel to tie the knot so we will be
here each week counting down to their
nuptials by bringing you the latest
updates on wedding planning and just all
the royal family news during this joyous
time because of course remember Duchess
Kate is bringing us some happiness to
baby number three is due in April and we
want to know what you guys think leave
your thoughts and questions in the
comments after all who doesn't love to
live vicariously through royalty so
starting off with some breaking news
Harry and Megan just hit their first
official evening events together in
England honoring servicemen and women
they went to the endeavour fund awards
on Thursday it was a rainy night Harry
donned a striking blue suit and a look
at Megan she went with a blazer and a
cropped pant yes a pant but we want to
note that's Alexander McQueen she's
wearing meanwhile Will and Kate were
over in Norway where they stunned at the
royal palace hate giving us full
bejeweled
Cape glam that's not another level and
now wedding planning
where we at a source tells ET Megan and
Harry are quote in the thick of it their
wedding date is coming up Saturday May
19th at Windsor Castle in England and
our source says megan has had her first
fitting with a dress designer a source
tells you team Megan's parents will be
involved in the ceremony that she wants
her 73 year old father who lives in a
quiet town in Mexico to be in England
and walk her down the aisle she is also
very close with her mother calls her her
best friend Megan's parents are divorced
but when the engagement was announced
they released a joint statement wishing
Megan and Harry happiness now while all
of that is traditional megan is already
getting a reputation for breaking the
British royalty mold she's American
she's an actress she wears messy buns
and the Sunday Times reports that she
might
yes speak on the wedding day yes Megan
is apparently considering giving a toast
at the reception which would be out of
the royalty norm there will be about 800
guests at that reception but one thing
that's up in the air is Duchess Kate
Middleton's involvement so let's move
into our royal reports we are looking at
Kate and Megan's relationship for this
report Megan and Harry said this when
the engagement was first announced it
has been amazing as William as well as
in support so Catherine's been amazing
but I want to bring in sophie scholl ac
because she has been monitoring all
things Will and Kate's come on in an
aside hi
so Sophie it seems like Kate and Megan
have been set up for a really successful
bond but what are those qualities that
are helping them get close as future
sisters-in-law well to start they're
actually both 36 they're the same age
but more importantly they are both non
Royals oh like us commoners yes so
they're coming from the same background
hopefully that means that Kate can kind
of mentor Megan through this transition
which is sure to be very difficult but
what I love here is how close Kate and
Harry have gotten over the years Harry's
been kind of a third wheel with Will and
Kate through the years and the two of
them have really developed the super
close bond so I imagine that has to
translate to her relationship with Megan
yeah totally if he's close with Kate
that'll help Kate get close with Megan
absolutely and they live close together
is this right yes they're neighbors at
the Kensington Palace Grounds and when
Harry and Megan get married they're
gonna move into an apartment and
essentially be just next-door neighbors
I love that though because an apartment
to us is very different than an
apartment to the Royals I think that
Will and Kate's apartment is like four
floors dancing tintin now what I do also
want to get into though is what exactly
Kate's involvement in the wedding is
going to be because at her sister
Pippa's wedding she wasn't even really
in the wedding party what do you think
will happen with Megan well it's unclear
what Kate's gonna be doing because she's
expecting her baby is due in April which
is about one month before the royal
wedding so we're not quite sure she's
gonna have to bounce back pretty quick
first of all yeah that's a big ask but
yeah yeah yeah
absolutely but her kids Charlotte and
George will be involved that we do know
that's gonna be adorable I love watching
them so I feel like you are my kid -
Megan kill ourselves Kate
meagan right now I'll take it Thank You
Sophie sure lacy Thank You Lauren she's
heading off to England herself if only
so Kate is still making the royal rounds
until she gives birth let's move over to
our rather regal looks of the week
highlighting all that fabulous royal
fashion on Wednesday kate channeled
princess diana yes look at this red
houndstooth coat custom-made for Kate by
Katherine Walker now Diana Believe It or
Not wore a stunning similar look back in
1990 and look at that she had young will
by her side love seeing that throwback
photo Kate put her own spin on the look
by pairing the coat with what we call an
almost burgundy Chanel handbag Kate and
Prince William are on a four-day royal
tour of Sweden and Norway what a life
they lead and that means fabulous winter
looks from Kate you guys love this big
furry hat and a long blue coat so simple
and so subtly showing off her growing
baby bump we also saw that bump in this
winter white dress that she wore the
couple is there speaking out about their
big cause that they're always advocating
for mental health but they had some fun
too Kate and we'll both put honey fuzzy
hats to play ice hockey Kate of course
there were a classic black Burberry coat
because you got to play hockey in style
and we're going to end things on a
little highborn humor that's my attempt
at an English accent Harry and Megan are
getting married at Windsor Castle
it's a family favorite the Queen spends
a lot of weekends there they have family
functions there but several outlets are
now analyzing the castle and talking
about how haunted it allegedly is
Windsor has actually had reports of more
than a dozen ghostly sightings over the
years apparently and one of those
purported ghosts is none other than King
Henry the eighth who seems a little
perturbed quote those that have
encountered the ghost of Henry the
eighth have described a large anxious
angry man pacing furiously and shouting
loudly so if Megan doesn't end up giving
a speech on the wedding day maybe Henry
can pipe in but what do you guys think
of the way that megan is planning on
breaking these royal traditions and how
are you liking Kate's fashion with
pregnancy number three let us know all
your thoughts in the comments thank you
so much for watching
e t--'s countdown to the Royal Wedding
and make sure to tune in
every Friday morning where we will have
the latest for you on wedding baby and
more thanks so much guys
[Music]